overall what kind of sense of are you
getting about the tone and the purpose
of this memoir
well the purpose was always to tell
Harry's truth in his own words a truth
he doesn't ever feel he's had the chance
to express before and I think I'm seeing
two themes to this we are seeing this
very difficult relationship with his
brother his beloved brother on one hand
his arch nemesis on the other that's
Harry's own words there and we're seeing
the relationship with the two of them
growing up as as brothers who jostled
and then ending in this situation in
2019 as brothers who then fought there
was a physical altercation over comments
William made to Harry when he went round
to his house about Megan uh describing
her as difficult as abrasive as rude and
there's something then led to William
grabbing hold of Harry uh throwing him
to the floor Harry hitting this dog bowl
cutting him as he hit the hit the floor
so we're getting a sense of this
physical difficulty with the
relationship how far that Rift had gone
and how far things have broken down
between the two of them but Harry is
also painting a picture the difficulty
growing up as playing second fiddle to
William if you like speaking of his
Eastern days in particular how it was a
school that William went to and said it
was his Sanctuary but he didn't like the
fact Harry had been there Harry is
saying to him a teacher Ethan said to
him don't forget you've got your brother
here Harry then writing but it wasn't me
who forgot Willie had told me to pretend
not to know him what you don't know me
Harold and I don't know you for the two
previous years William would explain to
him Eaton as I say had been his
Sanctuary so you get a sense there of
this difficult relationship between the
two brothers as I say on the one hand
Harry describing him as a beloved
brother and we've all seen the pictures
of them the bond was so close between
those two brothers and then we see the
other end of it where it's gone so
spectacularly wrong and then we're also
getting a bigger picture of the states
of Mind of Harry as a young teenager he
was just 12 years old when his mother
died the shock of having to deal with
that having to race members of the
public he has spoken about this period
before but we're getting a bit more
detail aren't we are having to shape the
hands of people wet hands because
they've been crying so much our Harry
himself hadn't cried and was questioning
why he hadn't cried like I say he has
covered this before but we are getting a
more of a sense of what perhaps led to
him age 17 taking cocaine and it wasn't
the first time he took cocaine he said
he took it at a friend's house after a
hunting party and then had taken on
other occasions he said he wanted to
feel different but he didn't come out as
happy as other people seem to
um when they'd taken the drugs so some
very personal details no comment yet
from the policy the Buckingham Palace or
Kensington Palace on this
um where we're talking about Camilla
though it's always been said this is a
red line as far as the King was
concerned so whether or not they can
hold that line of Silence we will have
to see